آه ، أنا متحمس حقًا لأن
أصبح جزءًا من هذا ، كما تعلم ، لقد رأيت
كيف دعم الاسكواش الإنجليزي نيك عندما
لعبت نيك القدير نيك وجيمس
عندما لعبت
ضدهم ولكي أكون صادقًا معك ستكون هذه هي
المرة الأولى في.  حياتي لدي بعض
الدعم في مسيرتي المهنية كما تعلم ، وهو
ما قد يفاجأ به الناس ، لكن
لم أحصل على أي دعم قبل أن أفعل
كل شيء
بنفسي لإنشاء فريقي الخاص ،
وكان علي أن أفعل كل هذه الأشياء بنفسي في
حياتي المهنية و
لأكون قادرًا على الشعور بأن هناك بعضًا من
أن الاسكواش الإنجليزي
قادم وسيأتون
ويدعمونني هذه هي المرة الأولى في حياتي التي
سأحصل فيها على دعم خلفي وهذا
سيساعدني في المحاولة  وأعود إلى
المصنفة الأولى في العالم مرة أخرى والفوز
بالألقاب ، أعرف كيف أفوز كما تعلمون ،
وأنا متحمس حقًا لهذا التحدي
لأكون صادقًا معك ولا يمكنني الانتظار